the new American Embassy to Israel is
open tonight in Jerusalem and that is
sparking a wide range of emotions from
jubilation among Israel and its
supporters in the Trump administration
to deadly rage from Palestinians and
their supporters throughout the world
while the president's daughter Ivanka
fronted a huge delegation from her
father's office
Palestinians clashed with Israeli troops
on the Gaza border resulting in dozens
of deaths and thousands of injuries that
is where we start tonight with
correspondent Benjamin Hall a campaign
promise fulfills today and with great
fanfare as the new US Embassy opened in
Jerusalem twenty-five years after
America first pledged to do so what a
glorious day remember this moment
President Trump by recognizing history
you have made history there was a
sizable US delegation among them Ivanka
Trump and Jared Kushner Stephen minuchin
and various members of Congress although
the president was not in attendance he
addressed the ceremony by video link
congratulations it's been a long time
coming the United States will always be
a great friend of Israel and a partner
in the cause of freedom and peace not
everyone was celebrating 53 miles south
the move inflamed the protests in Gaza
some 40,000 Palestinians staged
demonstrations along the border with
Israel leading to deadly clashes over 50
people were killed more than 2,300
wounded this has been the biggest
protest carried out by the Palestinians
since the protests began six weeks ago
it's also seen the biggest response from
the Israelis making this the deadliest
day since the war in 2014
Israeli military officials say they
foiled several coordinated attempts by
Palestinians to breach the fence pushing
them back with live fire they also
carried out airstrikes on Hamas camps
having warned the Palestinians in
advance we have to be very clear and
sharp and if needed forceful to defend
our border because Israeli civilians
lives are at stake
Estonian leaders say the move has ended
their trust in America forcing them to
walk away from peace talks
we considered America's embassy means
the end American control we will not go
back again to an American more protests
are planned tomorrow to commemorate what
Palestinians call the catastrophe of the
creation of the Jewish state but in
Israel today little can dampen the joy
at America's clear sign of commitment to
them a sentiment shared across political
divides has even Senate Minority Leader
Chuck Schumer praised the president for
moving the embassy saying he applauded
President Trump for doing so and only
two countries Guatemala and Paraguay
have said they'll follow suit and move
their embassy to Jerusalem and in news
just breaking in the last few hours
Turkey has just announced it is going to
put out its ambassador from the US both
in response to the move of the embassy
but also to the deaths of those
Palestinians and that is a big
diplomatic shift Brett
Benjamin Hall in Jerusalem Benjamin
thank you